etonnant non l'église catholique affirme
que le pape est infaillible
ça reste à prouver diront les sceptiques
et du franc maçon et bien justement rien
n'est plus simple que de prouver
l'infaillibilité du pape
vous pouvez le faire vous même sans
sortir de chez vous pour le pour le prix
d'un billet de train pour vierzon
même pas il suffit pour cela d'avoir le
pape sous la main c'est dans quelles
mains alors ouais j'avais gagné le pabx
et bien failli fait mon nom
[Musique]
trois fois plus débordés que la
secrétaire normal la secrétaire
trilingue est d'un abord volontiers avec
je suis d'un abord volontiers rendait ch
pour lui redonner ce bon sourire de
dinde aux pratiques si indispensable au
bon moral des prix chef de service
il serait tout à fait saugrenue
d'augmenter son salaire le plus simple
est de pratiquer sur elle le bluesy
gouzy part à la vie q les regarder bien
en la vache pieds touchent à la vacation
poupées des boues
stony shing note étonnant tonneaux
etonnant non
quand il a fini d'écrire ces conneries
dans le dictionnaire
l'académicien français ne sert plus à
rien c'est un parasite dans l'entretien
et la décoration coûte extrêmement cher
à la société maurel
c'est pourquoi afin de rentabiliser
l'immortel avant sa mort nous allons
nous en servir pour jouer à pinces
académiciens regardez bien pour bien
jouer à pinces académiciens il nous faut
une pince à linge et un académicien
alors la pince pinces et l'académicien
tourner
[Musique]
etonnant non
on peut diviser l'humanité en deux
catégories les gens de gauche qui sont
gentils et les gens de droite qui sont
méchants
mais attention les gens de droite ne le
font pas exprès ils sont de droite parce
qu'ils n'ont pas touché du doigt le fond
de la misère humaine
en effet il suffit de toucher du doigt
le fond de la misère humaine pour
devenir de gauche c'est simple regardez
bien vous regardez bien
et voilà j'ai touché du doigt le fond de
la misère humaine
je suis de gauche
étendons bon
[Musique]
landaluze est une fille farouche à
l'oeil de braise dont la danse échevelé
exprime douloureusement toute la fierté
ombrageuse de ce grand peuple orgue eu
ma dans ses cheveux les expriment
douloureusement la fierté ombrageuse
d'un grand peuple orgueilleux
malheureusement ses talons pointus et
c'est castagnettes fond de l'andalousie
un véhicule extrêmement bruyant c'est
pourquoi avant d'utiliser landaluze aux
abords des hôpitaux et des cimetières
nous devons préalablement l'un sonorisée
comment c'est très simple regardez bien
etonnant non bien qu'il n'y ait plus de
saison et quel prix du poireau ne cesse
d'augmenter
de nombreuses personnes renâclent à
l'idée de mourir un jour
eh bien j'ai une bonne nouvelle à partir
d'aujourd'hui plus personne ne mourra
jamais en effet je viens de faire une
découverte extraordinaire
la mort est contagieuse j'ai isolé le
virus de la mort je vais le détruire
maintenant devant vous et la mort sera
vaincu regardez bien
[Musique]
etonnant non
de très nombreuses personnes comme cette
téléspectatrice de lourdes nous font
part de la difficulté qu'elle éprouve à
se livrer à la débauche en pleine rue
jean jaurès à cause
et là je cite des promiscuité citadine
souvent malveillantes
eh bien madame bonne nouvelle pour vous
vous allez désormais pouvoir vous livrer
à vos plus effroyable pulsions sexuelles
en plein de rue jean jaurès sans risquer
de vous faire lapider
et ce grâce au xix gouzy drôme portable
du docteur brochard regardez bien alors
heureuse
ah oui un oui oui oui monsieur bonjour
là bonjour bonjour oui 1 grâce au
bouzouki idron portable l'exacerbation
de notre plaisir est désormais possible
et même en pleine rue jean jaurès ah oui
tenons
[Musique]
ô combien de marins
combien de capitaines qui sont partis
joyeux pour des courses lointaines en ce
morne horizons se sont évanouis
oui victor hugo le plus grands poètes de
tous les temps l'élévation de sa pensée
la grandiose majesté de ces alexandrins
ont plus fait pour le prestige de la
france que le camembert qui supporte
d'ailleurs moins bien le voyage
c'est pourquoi nous devons toujours
rendre hommage à victor hugo mais sans
bouger les oreilles parce que rendre
hommage à victor hugo en bouchant les
oreilles ce serait un sacrilège et je le
prouve ô combien de marins combien de
capitaines qui sont partis joyeux pour
des courses lointaines en ce morne
horizons se sont évanouis
etonnant non
en temps de paix le général de brigade
s'étiole la monotonie des jours sans
carnage assombri son beau regard d'aigle
ce que nous faudrait une bang
il n'a personne à tuer ils se sentent
inutiles ce qu'il nous faudrait une
bonne guerre
dieu merci la ménagère avisé saura
utiliser le général de brigade à
d'humbles tâches domestiques afin de lui
redonner sa joie de vivre entre deux
guerres mondiales
comment d'un c'est très simple regardez
je
et
etonnant non
[Musique]
les deux tiers de l'humanité meurent de
faim au moment même où je vous parle
dans le monde entier des millions
d'enfants famélique
ce fan doucement avant même d'avoir vécu
pendant ce temps que fait l'homme
occidental est bien l'homme occidental
se gavent de viandes grasses et il se
boursoufle de saindoux et c'est
dégoûtant allons nous supporter plus
longtemps je dis non c'est pourquoi dès
maintenant nous allons tous ensemble
observé une minute sans dodaine pour
tous les enfants affamés du monde entier
alors si vous le voulez bien à moi
commandement 1 2 3 etonnant non
[Musique]
afin de ne pas être ridicule en société
il faut absolument savoir reconnaître
une gardienne d'immeuble d'un oléoduc
certes à première vue rien ne les
distingue l'un de l'autre mais avec un
peu d'entraînement nous devons y arriver
alors et alors seulement nous ne serons
plus celui dont on rit en disant ah il a
donné des étrennes à son oléoduc ou
encore à il a rempli sa conscience de
pétrole mais comment faire du ring eh
bien c'est très simple
regardez bien
paulette je m'appelle pour l'une
brochard avec un dé et ben oui vous avez
compris le pipeline s'appelle paulette
et la pipelette s'appelle pauline
etonnant non l'homme qui va se présenter
maintenant devant vos yeux révulsés par
l'horreur et répugnons l'indicible
vulgarité de ses traits grotesque font
de lui un être repoussant immonde
épouvantable cependant cette raclure
d'humanité nettel pointe elle aussi une
créature de dieu
quoique vous vend table je suis une
créature de dieu vous coller et malgré
sa laideur n'at-il pas le droit lui
aussi à l'amour et bien si seulement
comment faire pour le transformer en un
gendre présentable et bien c'est très
simple il suffit d'un bon coup de peigne
tout simplement
regardez bien
tournon
quoi de plus bouleversant qu'une
paimpolaise papa me polèse bigoudène
paimpolaise dévorer d'angoise guettant
le retour de son marin si ce n'est deux
peuples l'aise dévorer d'angoise
guettant le retour de leurs marins ça
pour ce qui est de la angoisse on peut
dire que je suis dévorer certes rien ne
lui rendra son cher mari qui gît
désormais par 3000 mètres de fond avec
un poulpe sur la tête et un harpon dans
l'oeil mais il serait cruel de la [ __ ]
à l'eau pour autant car la bougresse
peut encore servir
je peux encore servir à quoi dire et
vous regardez bien
[Musique]
etonnant non les communistes ne sont pas
des gens comme nous ils renversent les
monarchies ils bafouent les libertés et
ils mangent les enfants
certains même ne vont pas à la messe
c'est pourquoi nous devons apprendre à
bien reconnaître un communiste afin de
pouvoir le dénoncer aux autorités
d'occupation aux autorités comment
reconnaître un communiste et bien c'est
très simple grâce à la radioscopie
regardez bien la voici tout d'abord la
radioscopie d'un homme normal
1 nous voyons très nettement le coeur et
l'âme il en va tout autrement du
communiste nous avons ici la radioscopie
d'un communiste que constatons-nous et
bien tout simplement nous voyons très
nettement qu'il n'a pas d'âme et qu'il
n'a pas de coeur la honte l'envahir
lahontan valises
[Musique]
etonnant non
pour qu'un couple soit une réussite et
que triomphe l'amour il faut que l'homme
et la femme est des goûts communs et une
sensibilité commune et bien sûr qu'ils
gagnent au moins trente mille francs par
mois mais ce n'est pas tout en effet
sans une parfaite harmonie sexuelle
la densité de notre passion s'effiloche
ray au fil des jours tel le nuage
moribond qui ces cartels aux vents
mauvais c'est pourquoi nous allons
apprendre ensemble dès aujourd'hui les
32 position de l'amour aujourd'hui
première position
regardez bien 1 2 3
[Musique]
etonnant non les français aiment les
escargots
mais les escargots n'aime pas les
français
c'est pourquoi nous devons nous méfier
des escargots qui sous des dehors
volontiers bonenfant cache en réalité
une âme de fois on prête à bondy
heureusement heureusement grâce à
l'amitié franco espagnole nous viendrons
à bout d estaing
[Musique]
les espagnols sont un peuple fier et
ombrageux avec un tout petit cul pour
éviter les coups de corne
c'est ce qui fait des espagnols les
meilleurs alliés de la france dans la
lutte contre les escargots
on est volé pour les colimaçons au
niveau tonnes ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étonnant pour tuer le temps en attendant
la mort de nombreuses personnes jouent à
pinces millet pincemoi avec l'être cher
pincemi et pincemoi sont dans un bateau
passe me tombe à l'eau qu'est ce qui
reste
passe moi
malheureusement il arrive qu'ils quand
on a joué pendant plusieurs heures
d'affilée à pince mi pince moi une
certaine lassitude apparaissent chez
l'un des joueurs ou même si l'aide
c'est pourquoi j'ai inventé une variante
très amusante à ce jeu regardez bien ce
jeu s'appelle bombarde me bombarde mois
il se joue ainsi bombardier bombarde
mois sont dans un bateau bombard me
tombent dans l'eau qu'est ce qui reste
bombard mois
etonnant non
[Musique]
de nombreux messieurs s'étonne de ne pas
plaire aux femmes alors qu'ils sont
beaux riches intelligent et chrétiens
c'est sans doute qu'ils ont des points
noirs disgracieux j'ai des points noirs
discussion heureusement j'ai fait une
découverte incroyable
j'ai en effet constaté que pour faire
disparaître les points noirs
il suffisait de les peindre en blanc
regardez bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
à nous les filles etonnant non
[Musique]
de très nombreuses personnes s'imaginent
que pour voir apparaître la sainte
vierge
il suffit de ramasser du bois mort dans
les pyrénées-orientales en enjambant le
ruisseau
c'est fou pour être sûr de bien voir
apparaître la vraie sainte vierge
il faut de surcroît être une humble
bergère regardez bien
[Musique]
ah bah oui mais quand on n'est pas une
vraie bergère faut pas s'attendre à voir
apparaître une vierge
voilà maintenant non
[Musique]
quoi de plus cruel que la perte d'un
être cher
si ce n'est la perte de deux êtres chers
or il arrive qu'au moment de nous rendre
aux obsèques de l'être cher
nous apprenions que nous venons de
gagner au loto ou vous que la france a
battu la belgique
alors comment faire pour masquer notre
joie au pied du cercueil est plus simple
rien de plus simple grâce au mime et
lost hausse grâce à ses deux fils
invisibles et nous cachons habilement au
fond de nos poches
notre irrépressible hilarité se
transformera en un instant on est une
tristesse poignante
regardez bien al'inverse imaginons que
le jour du mariage de notre fille
préférée
nous apprenions que la france était
battue par la belgique ou encore que
nous avons perdus ouloto et bien grâce
au mime et la sauce en inversant les
mouvements nous pourrons masquer notre
peine profonde comme ceci
[Musique]
étonnant
la vague et me le cul de jatte apitoie
mais le sourd prête à rien et pourtant
comme il est cruel ce monde de solitude
dans lequel le sourd se croyant inutile
se demande à quoi sert humaine où se
demande à quoi sert humainement la vie
sans les oreilles c'est pourquoi afin de
venir en aide à notre misérable frère le
sourd j'ai inventé pour lui un fauteuil
[Musique]
c'est le premier fauteuil pour sourds du
monde un certain première vue rien ne le
distingue d'un fauteuil ordinaire et
regardez bien
vous êtes bien mon brave homme
tenant afin de ne pas être ridicule en
société il est très important d'être
capable d'authentifier la joconde
au premier coup d'oeil or il existe dans
le monde des milliers de fausses los
condes alors que le nombre de vrais
joconde est beaucoup plus restreint j'ai
ici près de moi deux secondes je suis la
joconde je suis la joconde
à première vue rien ne distingue l'une
de l'autre mais regardez bien
[Musique]
où
bien oui vous avez compris la vraie
joconde est peinte à la main
la fosse je compte spanta la gnôle
étonnant non
[Musique]
quoi de plus réconfortant ce siècle
glace est figé engoncé dans son froid
rigorisme que de constater encore
l'exquise sagesse de ses vieux dicton
populaire que nos ancêtres gorgée de vin
rouge et boursouflée d'idées reçues
je t'ai jadis dans l'âtre au coeur
paisible des soirée campagnarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais direz vous ces vieux dicton n'ont
ils pas pris quelques rides et bien pour
le savoir nous pourrions prendre une
pierre qui roule et un peu de mousse
mais il ya mieux
eh bien oui le vieux dicton a raison
chihuahua bout du chihuahua foutu
etonnant non
en temps de paix le kamikaze n'a plus de
raison de sauter sur quoi que ce soit
d'un flamme à bhl il s'étiole le suicide
était le seul but de son existence
maintenant qu'il n'a plus de raisons de
mourir il n'a plus de raison de vivre
ces thématiques que les tifs est-il tête
puis matin à fond heureusement grâce à
la charité chrétienne
il est désormais possible d'aider un
kamikaze en finir une bonne fois pour
toutes avec la vie en déclenchant chez
lui cette irrépressible envie d'exploser
sur l'ennemi qui lui valu naguère son
immense prestige auprès des gonzesses
comment faire direz vous et bien c'est
simple il suffit d'imiter le cri du
porte avions
regardez bien pout pout pout pout pout
pout pout pout 25
[Musique]
etonnant non
avant
le but de l'homme moderne sur cette
terre est à l'évidence de s'agiter sans
réfléchir dans tous les sens afin de
pouvoir dire fièrement à l'heure de sa
mort
ah j'ai pas perdu mon temps
malheureusement malgré toute sa bonne
volonté
l'homme est souvent contraint de
galvauder ce temps précieux en vulgaire
et mesquine manifestation de sa vie
animale dont l'amour est là ce n'est pas
la moindre
c'est pourquoi afin de réduire au
minimum ce temps consacré à aimer son
prochain
l'homme a tout intérêt à aimer de
préférence à toute autre femme
la star du muet dont l'exquis silence
n'a d'égal que l'extrême célérité à et
maintenant non
[Musique]
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
obtenus par nos camarades par vos
camarades
après des années de lutte les
travailleurs les plus démunis vont
désormais pouvoir s'opérer eux mêmes
sans risquer de s'endormir pendant le
dépeçage
je m'appelle sandrine brouch a je suis
tourneuse frise 2002 à vierzon madame
sandrine brochard va maintenant réaliser
devant vous sur son visage grotesque
la première intervention d'auto
chirurgie esthétique
comment c'est simple regardez bien
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
qui ouvre aux travailleurs les portes de
l'auto chirurgie les pauvres aussi ont
droit à la beauté que belle que moi tu
meurs
etonnant non jovial jusqu'à friser
l'hébétude la majorette affichant toutes
circonstances sur son visage hilare
la fringante sérénité des êtres que nul
doute m'habite
j'affiche sur mon visage il à la
fringante sérénité des êtres que nul
tout n'habite en toutes circonstances
[Musique]
il arrive qu'à la longue les
contemporains de la majorette prennent
ombrage de cette insupportable image du
bonheur et bien pour y mettre fin c'est
très simple il suffit d'être armé d'une
haine tenace pour tout ce qui est beau
et d'un bar à belhom 9 mm
[Musique]
etonnant non
de nombreux indécis de révolutionnaire
originaires de diverses démocratie
tyrannique en voie de développement me
demandent la marche à suivre pour
abattre la dictature étouffante qui les
oppriment pendant les heures ouvrables
ligne c'est très simple regardez bien
dans un premier temps pour abattre la
dictature
il faut renverser le tyran je suis le
garant vous regardez bien une fois que
le tyran est renversée il suffit de le
retourner pour pouvoir jouer à saute
dictateur est étonnant non
[Musique]
pour peu qu'on l'agaçant blasphème en
son sein non il arrive que dieu entre
dans un état second
bien connue sous le nom de colère de
dieu le plus souvent la colère de dieu
se manifeste sous la forme de grandiose
tempête wagnérienne dont l'énergie
malheureusement se dilue en pure perte
au vent mauvais alors même que le prix
du pétrole et du poireau ne cesse
d'augmenter
c'est pourquoi nous devons rentabiliser
la colère de dieu comment c'est simple
regardez bien je vais maintenant appelés
sur moi la colère de dieu afin de
limiter au maximum les risques
d'excommunication et d'implosion je
prierai tout d'abord les chrétiens
congénitaux de bien vouloir s'écarter de
leurs récepteurs merci attention
nom de dieu
nom de dieu nom de dieu
[Musique]
ja oui grâce à la colère de dieu j'ai
économisé une allumette
etonnant non
[Musique]
m
le rasage du matin le pointage à l'
usine et le devoir conjugal sont les
trois mamelles du travailleur moderne
mais trois mamelles d'espoir une de trop
dieu merci grâce à la stupéfiante
fécondité de mes récents travaux
j'ai réussi à débarrasser l'humanité de
l'une de ces épouvantables corvées
quotidiennes le rasage du matin comment
c'est simple regardez bien eh bien oui
grâce au premier rasoir jetable avant
usage le rasage du matin n'est plus une
corvée
etonnant non afin de ne pas être
ridicule en société il est très
important de savoir reconnaître un
naturel d'un naturiste or à première vue
rien ne les distingue l'un de l'autre
à un détail près le naturel est à plumes
et le naturiste est à poil mais pour
bien les distinguer l'un de l'autre et
ne plus être l'objet des nazis du gotha
le plus simple est encore de les chasser
regardez bien je vous chasse premières
constatations
quand on chasse le naturiste il ne
revient pas johnny chan
[Musique]
deuxième constatation quand on chasse le
naturel il revient au boulot justement
de très nombreux imbéciles légitimement
boursouflé de complexe d'infériorité me
font part des difficultés qu'ils
éprouvent à masquer leur vulgarité
congénitale dans les soirées
protocolaire en effet afin de ne pas
être ridicule en société il est
primordial de savoir reconnaître au
premier coup d'oeil le grand-père du
pape du père du patriarche d'athènes
pour prendre un exemple courant
or me direz vous à première vue rien ne
distingue rien d'autre alors comment
faire
et bien c'est très simple
regardez bien je suis la paire de sa
béatitude
je suis le grand père de sa sainteté et
bien oui vous avez compris le papa du
pop a du pain est le papy du papa des
poux papa du pape alé pour lui etonnant
non
afin d'inaugurer un poisson rouge avec
tout le faste et la seule la nit est
requise
il suffit d'avoir un poisson rouge une
ficelle une bouteille de champagne d'un
certain âge et une veuve de maréchal de
france millésimé
[Applaudissements]
mais attention l'âge de la bouteille de
champagne et de la veuve de maréchal de
france sont moins importants que la
longueur de la ficelle c'est ce que je
dis toujours mon âge n'a aucune espèce
d'importance
ce qui compte c'est la longueur de la
ficelle en la longueur de la ficelle
c'est ça qui compte
pourquoi c'est simple regardez bien
etonnant non
afin de 100 bus et le cortex avec des
mouvements souvenir de carnage
d'internationaux il arrive que l'homme
se regroupent en petits tas monrose pour
respecter une minute de silence
sans vouloir le mois du monde
dénigrer cette institution sacrée du
génie humain
force nous est cependant de constater
que la minute de silence pour qui la vie
avec toute l'intensité et le
recueillement souhaité est extrêmement
longue
comment faire alors pour tuer le temps
pendant ces 60 longues secondes
et bien c'est très simple
rendez vos cheveux
cuire le attirant et d'autre
à part le défunt lui-même qui n'en a
plus rien à secouer la plupart des
proches venus rendre un ultime hommage à
la dépouille mortelle d'un chers
disparus s'emmerde profondément lors de
la traditionnelle veillée funèbre
je m'emmerde profondément pourtant avec
un brin d'humour et un peu de bonne
volonté il est facile de devenir à peu
de frais celui ou celle dont on dira ah
j'ai veillé son dessin tentons aussi
bien amusé comment c'est simple regardez
bien c'est un moment de très nombreux
catholiques pratiquants s'indignent et
s'insurgent avec véhémence contre les
impudents gougnafiers anticléricaux
primaire et autres actes et viscéraux
fanatiques qui se moquent publiquement
de la religion c'est grossier personnage
ne méritent ils pas d'être excommunié et
bien une seule personne au monde est
habilité à répondre clairement et
définitivement à cette grave question et
cette personne c'est le chef de l'église
lui-même sa sainteté le pape alors très
saint père je vous le demande tout c'est
grossier personnage qui se moquent
publiquement de la religion ne sont ils
pas menacé d'excommunication par le
courroux de dieu
tout
eh bien non
[Rires]
[Musique]
chaque année au coeur de l'automne merci
depuis le début des temps et
probablement jusqu'à la fin du monde
une famille entière d'imbéciles et
décimé par les champignons vénéneux
ouais les champignons je connais et cela
malgré les remarques réitéré des
autorités médicales les plus compétentes
et des sommités mycologique les moins
farfelues voit les champignons je
connais c'est pourquoi afin d'éviter une
mort grotesque nous ne devons jamais
allés nous promener dans les bois sans
un conte un champignon voici un conte un
champignon voit les champignons je
connais
au moindre doute de votre part le conte
un champignon se fera une joie de goûter
à votre place le champignon suspect
lui les champignons il connaissait
etonnant non
[Musique]
une poignée de crétins coach of ages me
demande pourquoi les cochons orientaux
affiche en permanence c'est air arrogant
c'est pourtant simple vivent dans un
pays où la religion interdit
formellement la consommation de la
viande de porc
le cochon orientale ne craint pas pour
ses côtelettes
c'est pourquoi il a toujours la truffe
narquoise et le gros insuffisant mais
alors direz vous pourquoi les musulmans
ne bouffent t-il pas cet imbécile qui
fait rien qu'à se moquer d'eux
si vous croyez que c'est facile etonnant
non
le puritanisme de la reine victoria est
aussi légendaire que par exemple la
lubricité d'henri iv ou la connerie du
général gamelin l'historien gerald
charolles materials affirme notamment
que la souveraine allait jusqu'à
éteindre la lumière avant d'ôter sa
couronne afin de ne passer moustier la
libido à ce spectacle charmant
d'autres en revanche disent qu'il ne
s'agissait en fait que d'une
pudibonderie de façade imposé par la
raison d'état qu'en est il en réalité
est bien le plus simple pour le savoir
n'est-il pas de pénétrer subrepticement
dans l'intimité de la reine victoria
l'aise
one more time one more time et toning
note
[Musique]
il peut arriver que l'élu de notre coeur
pour peu qu'elles étaient élevés dans la
religion ou qu'elle ait oublié sa pilule
est quelquefois les deux se refuse avec
ostentation a livré son corps pulpeux o
car est insensé de la main du désir que
la morale réprouve
en dehors des liens sacrés du mariage tu
me refuse avec ostentation à livrer mon
corps pulpeux aux caresses insensé de la
main du désir que la morale réprouve en
dehors des liens sacrés du mariage
rien n'est pourtant plus simple que de
faire succomber la bougresse à
l'impétuosité pétaradante de notre
fringant amour il suffit en effet de
jouer avec elle a promis prends moi sont
dans un bateau un jeu infiniment subtil
dans la paternité mes choix premier
prends moi sont dans un bateau promis
tombe dans l'eau qu'est ce qui reste
en mai
etonnant non
démuni de tout écartelé entre le prix
exorbitant du topinambour et la hausse
inexorable des loyers des taudis le
pauvre crie famine famille merci digne
dans la douleur sublime de résignation
c'est malheureux sont nombreux à me
faire part de leur souhait de ne pas
mourir sans savoir à quoi ressemble un
gros billet de banque car l'argent du
style on entend souvent parler mais on
n'en voit pas souvent la couleur
eh bien chers pauvres soyez exaucé vous
allez enfin voir la couleur de l'argent
regardez bien alors voyez vous c'est
jaune c'est passé dans les journaux et
le commandant
en amour on est toujours 2 1 qui
s'emmerdent est inquiet malheureux je
m'emmerde
je suis malheureux cependant que nous
soyons celui qui malheureux ou celui qui
s'emmerde
c'est à l'intérieur des liens sacrés du
mariage et nulle part ailleurs que nous
devons apprendre à épanouir notre libido
ne serait ce que pour limiter au maximum
les risques d'excommunication elle met
près des voisins c'est pourquoi afin
d'exalter à la maison nous devons
apprendre ensemble les trente deux
positions de l'amour
aujourd'hui première position regardez
bien alors ça là n'est ce pas et ça la
voyez vous comme ça non pas comme ça
comme ça comme ça oui et ça l'a la wii
s'est très bien
en effet c'était pas tant etonnant non
[Musique]
l'homme moderne se doit de fustiger avec
véhémence toutes les formes de racisme
après tout les gens de couleurs ne sont
ils pas des gens comme nous comme vous
malheureusement il est extrêmement
difficile de prévoir une émeutes
raciales
c'est pourquoi il vaut mieux attendre
que les émeutes raciales et commencer
afin de pouvoir la mater grâce à cette
ultime rempart de la civilisation contre
la barbarie que constitue le para bellum
9 mm attention je vais maintenant
déclenché une émeute raciale comment
c'est simple regardez bien eh bien oui
vous avez compris pour bien mater une
émeutes raciales
il faut tirer sur les blancs avec une
balle à blanc et sur les noirs avec une
banane war le seigneur a dit tu aimeras
ton prochain comme toi même
personnellement je préfère moi même et
j'ai horreur qu'on tutoie cependant avec
un peu d'entraînement nous pouvons
parvenir à aimer notre prochain
presqu'autant que moi même la meilleure
façon d'aimer notre prochain comme moi
même consiste à l'intégrer le plus
naturellement du monde à nos jeux les
plus humbles ainsi vais-je maintenant
jouer à colin maillard avec ce
sympathique aveugle et chic
karl aveugle elle seule prochain qu'ils
soient toujours prêts à jouer à colin
maillard sans le moindre accessoire
regardez bien qui moi non pas vous prêts
bref c'est la règle d'un an de nombreux
tintinophiles me demande où se trouve
actuellement le fils caché de tintin
bien le plus simple c'est encore d'aller
demander atteinte à lui même depuis sa
naissance entre les deux guerres
tintin n'a pas pris une seule ride ce
qu'il surveille très étroitement son
alimentation et qu'il s'interdit toute
activité sexuelle fatigante
depuis la mort de son cher milou tout
cela ne nous dit pas où est le fils
caché tintin je suis la tête une au papa
[Musique]
émouvant etonnant non
une poignée d'imbéciles me demande
quelle est l'origine de la fête de
l'épiphanie au cours de laquelle comme
chacun sait à part une poignée
d'imbéciles
nous avons coutume de tirer les rois
c'est simple le mot épiphanie vient du
grec
et puis qui veut dire tirer et fanny qui
veut dire les rois alors pour bien tirer
les rois
il faut les rois il nous faut également
un fusil mitrailleur fm à x z623 5,5
il ne nous reste plus qu'à attendre que
chaque roi et prononcer une dernière
parole historique inoubliable l'état
c'était moi sur une gamme bifteck
parking veni vedi vie c est maintenant
pour sauver la république
tirons les rois non non ce soir
exceptionnellement en hommage à
l'inventeur de l'espéranto
le dr bouchard dont nous fêtons
aujourd'hui le centenaire de la
naissance de la soeur nous allons
observer ensemble une seconde de silence
merci avant l'invention de l'espéranto
le barrage de la langue constitue est
une inépuisable source de discorde entre
les hommes
rappelez vous
puis je vous demander du feu s'il vous
plaît fais une kodela tarder aujourd'hui
grâce à l'espéranto
nous pouvons en jambes et avec
allégresse les infranchissable
frontières du langage regardez bien puis
je vous demande à du futile s'il vous
plaît désolât jeu permet à l'ue mais tu
y penses look et o nine et tonine
étonnant non
peut-on dissoudre la monarchie certes
nom s'écrit les royalistes fanatiques
hystérique à la solde des bourbons bien
sûr que si rétorquent les démocrates
congénitaux à la solde de la république
alors qui croire qui croire direz vous
et bien une fois de plus c'est de la
rigueur de l'expérience scientifique que
jaillira la lumière pour réussir cette
expérience il suffit d'avoir sous la
main une bonbonnes d'acide sulfurique
une barrique et louis xiv anvers
lentement l'acide sulfurique et on
attend une bonne seconde
[Musique]
eh bien oui le peuple a raison le 14 est
soluble dans la city fut l'état etonnant
non
[Musique]
je terry brival au jeu terrible de la
roulette russe
il est très difficile de gagner à tous
les coups néanmoins afin de mettre un
maximum de chance dans son camp le
joueur avisé aura tout intérêt à
pratiquer de préférence ce sport délicat
avec un imbécile
regardez bien alors nous prenons un
revolver à six coups dans lequel il n'y
a qu'une seule balle et attention c'est
à vous plus que cinq
plus que quatre plus que trois le qe2
plus qu'une
je passe
il est 9 niet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
près de quarante ans après que les
restes calcinés d'adolphe hitler et
d'eva braun est été retrouvés dans
berlin en flammes
les historiens restent partagés sur les
circonstances exactes de la mort du
führer du troisième reich et de sa
gonzesse
que s'est il passé réellement des bases
et simple
regardez ma main c'est qui qui descend
la poubelle c'est toi hier c'était moi
alors ça me ferait mal c'était moi hier
soir à merde alors hier c'était moi j'en
suis sûr je me vois encore qu'il est
vraiment trop con c'est celui qui le dit
qui y'est et aux niches
avec ma fait
mieux vaut se tromper tout seul qu'avoir
raison avec les autres disait le poète
anarchiste
peut-être il n'empêche que la solitude
est lourde au coeur de l'homme en ce
siècle classées au bien sûr pour tromper
sa solitude on peut toujours essayer ça
la tienne chéri
mais le miroir reste de glace il ne
répond pas alors que seule la chaleur de
la voix humaine peut apporter le
réconfort malheureux solitaire bonjour
monsieur ça va bien j'écoute
vous avez beau temps etonnant non
[Musique]
le martyre c'est la seule façon de
devenir célèbre quand on n'a pas de
talent disait claudel ou marx ainsi
sainte-blandine figure-t-elle
aujourd'hui encore en toute première
place au hit parade des martyrs célèbre
et on peut l'applaudir
merci chacun sait que blandine fut
livrée aux lions pour avoir dessiné des
petites croix sur les murs de rome or la
jeune chrétienne fut miraculeusement
épargné par le faux authentique mais
s'agissait-il bien un miracle
eh bien non regardez bien
ben oui vous avez compris bourrés de
colorants sainte-blandine étaient
immangeables
etonnant non
tout fout le camp
nos plus nobles traditions se perdent
aujourd'hui par exemple on ne pouvait
même plus les présidents de la
république avant de les sortir
tu l'as dit bouffi et si on continue de
leur cirer les pompes
il y avait belle lurette qu'on ne relève
plus les pieds il y a deux siècles la
populace était bien plus respectueuse de
son souverain
je veux mon neveu savez vous qu en 1783
tenez vous bien tenez vous mieux merci
en 1783 avant de montrer un feu
d'artifice royal on allait jusqu'à
ignifuges et louis saez
[Musique]
ainsi le roi de france était totalement
inapte la map
ça aurait été moins con digne fugier
jeanne d'arc
etonnant non
[Musique]
sous des dehors de grosses brutes
vulgaire le boxeur moyen cache en
réalité une arme de grosses brutes
vulgaire est ce à dire que le boxeur
n'est capable d' aucun sentiment humain
pour le savoir c'est très simple il
suffit d'avoir sous la main une
chanteuse populaire ordinaire un vieux
tourne-disque en état de marche et un
boxeur quelconque
alors regardez bien écoutez bien mais
vous pleurez milou etonnant non
[Musique]
de nombreux mélomanes nom comprenant
sont persuadés que beethoven et 90 ans
dans ces faux beterz n'était pas sourd
méthode était con et je le prouve
non réfléchissez encore monsieur
beethoven il ne vous affolez pas je
repose ma question combien y at-il de
pommes sur cette table but non plus de 8
non je vous en prie recompter les
calmement
etonnant non
[Musique]
de très nombreux amateurs d'art nom
comprenant me demande s'il existe un
moyen discret de reconnaître au premier
coup d'oeil la joconde du choco
[Musique]
certes à première vue rien ne distingue
la joconde du jeu qu'on alors
réfléchissons prends ta tête à demain
mon cousin
comment reconnaissons nous est
habituellement un homme d'une femme ou
homme s'essuie qui va à la gare ouais
mais en temps de paix mais non en temps
de guerre comme en temps de paix on
reconnaît la joconde du jeu qu'on
exactement de la même façon qu'on
reconnaît un homme d'une femme à la
forme de son vélo etonnant non
[Musique]
grâce à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse la femme moderne peut
désormais sortir la tête haute et le
ventre plat mais un nouveau pas vers
l'humanisation de la médecine peut
encore être franchies
je veux parler non plus de l' ivg mais
deux lives et l'interruption volontaire
de vieillesse voyez ce septuagénaire de
70 ans je m'emmerde
qu'attend t-il encore de la vie rien du
tout notre devoir
n'est-il point de pratiquer sur l'huile
iv v afin d'abréger son ennui
si bien sûr à une seule condition que
l'intéressé lui même donne son accord
alors monsieur vous êtes d'accord pour
que nous pratiquions sur vous
l'interruption volontaire de vieillesse
allons témoin cette seconde
merci de toute façon à cet âge là ils
servent plus qu'ils disent etonnant non
contrairement à ce que croit le commun
des mortels l'alsacienne moyenne est
beaucoup plus qu'une simple berrichonne
son envergure exceptionnelle la
gracilité de son empennage la beauté de
sa queue fond de l'alsacienne un
volatile très apprécié des connaisseurs
ça quand je dois dire que pardon
malheureusement l'alsacienne d'un
naturel volontiers casanier renâcle le
plus souvent à l'idée de prendre son
envol
je renâclent à l'idée de prendre mon
c'est pourquoi afin de faciliter son
décollage nous irons d'un aimable
stratagème à base de saucisses de
strasbourg
allez hop hop
[Musique]
etonnant non
de nombreuses abc anti bonapartiste
primaires me demande si napoléon et bien
en enfer bien le plus simple c'est
encore d'y aller voir sa gueule et oui
alors même où je vous parle
napoléon cuit qui l'eût cru élégant
direz vous
s'est il envolé au paradis d'un coup
d'aile fragile et désespéré hélas non le
roi de rome a rejoint son papa en enfer
etonnant non
[Musique]
dans le peloton cliquetant des ordures
galonnés qui ont fait trembler le monde
sous la terreur infernal de leur
tyrannie hystérique adolf hitler vient
largement en tête les deux parades un
être aussi abject est il capable du
moindre sentiment humain est bien pour
le savoir il nous suffit de suivre
l'immonde tirant dans sa promenade
matinale
regardez bien bonjour madame brochard
bonjour monsieur le grumier de nos jours
les gens ne respectent plus rien eh bien
oui
hitler était capable d'un sentiment
humain il souffrait quand on lui disait
pas bonjour
etonnant non
[Musique]
à la suite de ma démonstration du
fauteuil pour sourds de nombreux 90 ans
dans nom comprenant me font part de leur
inquiétude
s'agit-il bien là d'un fauteuil
spécifiquement conçus pour nous may cry
un sourd de lourdes hautes pyrénées un
aveugle peu scrupuleux ne pourrait-il
pas tenté de s'asseoir dans notre
fauteuil
et bien soyez rassurés est chère sous le
fauteuil pour sourds été conçu pour vous
les sourds et pour vous seul regardez
bien je prenne mois un magnifique
fauteuil pour sourds et un aveugle
quelconque
alors regardez bien moi non pas vous
vous tenez vous prêts 1 2 3 à 6 etonnant
non
[Musique]
c'est non non